[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
presseub an dies Sonntag ein Monat ist
vergangen seit dem barbarischen Überfall
der Terrororganisation Hamas auf Israel
bei dem über 1400 Menschen getötet
wurden und über 200 Geiseln in den
Gasastreifen verschleppt worden sind
nach dem Überfall hat Israel
Gegenangriffe auf den Gazastreifen
gestartet und diese kontinuierlich
intensiviert täglich sterben dabei auch
palästinensische Zivilisten das liegt
unter anderem daran dass der
Gazastreifen sehr dicht besiedelt ist
und die mit lieder der
Terrororganisation mitten unter den
Zivilisten Leben der Beschuss eines
Krankenwagens und der Angriff auf das
Flüchtlingslager jabalia das sieht man
hier im Bild werfen Fragen auf z.B wie
verhältnismäßig das israelische Vorgehen
mit Blick auf seine militärischen Ziele
ist und vor allem fehlt eine Idee was
nach der militärischen
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Gasastreifen
oder dem was danach noch davon übrig ist
geschehen soll damit damit unmittelbar
verknüpft ist die Frage ob es eine
politische Lösung für Israelis und
Palästinenser geben kann und wie diese
aussehen könnte unser Thema im
Presseclub heute Ausweg gesucht wie ist
der Nahe Osten zu retten und das sind
meine Gäste die ich alle zusammen
herzlich begrüße Markus Bickel er ist
Teamleiter der außen und
Sicherheitspolitik beim digitalen
Medienhaus table Media und war viele
Jahre nach ostkorrespondent unter
anderem für die FAZ Robert chat er ist
stellvertretender Chefredakteur beim
nahostfachmagazin Zenit scharsard Eden
osterer sie ist deutsch-iranische
Journalistin Autorin und Moderatorin
unter anderem für den bayischen Rundfunk
und Anna Sauerbrei sie ist
außenpolitische Koordinatorin für die
Wochenzeitung Die Zeit wie immer können
Sie diese Sendung auch in den sozialen
Medien verfolgen und sich an der
Diskussion dort
beteiligen der US-amerikanische
Außenminister Anthony blinken erreist
aktuell durch den nahen Osten und er ist
jetzt wohl in ramala gewesen er hat
Palästinenser Präsident Mahmud Abbas
getroffen zumindest sind davon Bilder
veröffentlicht worden er setzt sich für
eine humanitäre Pause ein die arabischen
Staaten wollen gar einen
Waffenstillstand israel lehnt bislang
jedoch all das ab was Frau Sauerbrei
wäre denn ihrer Meinung nach jetzt der
nächste richtige Schritt um die
Situation nicht weiter eskalieren zu
lassen es glaube ein nächster wichtiger
Schritt wäre dass die human Tiere
Situation der palästinensischen
Zivilisten im Gaza Streifen verbessert
wird die Lage ist dort im Moment sehr
schlecht die Menschen dort waren schon
vor diesem Krieg sehr stark abhängig von
humanitären Hilfsleistung von
lebensmittelmikamenten die alle von
außen in den gaserstreifen gebracht
wurden und im Moment hängt es einfach an
einem kleinen Nadelör dem ägyptischen
Grenzübergang rafach und der kann nicht
bei bei weitem nicht so viele Laster
abfertigen wie eigentlich rein müssten
das heißt da muss weiter Druck ausgeübt
werden von der internationalen
Gemeinschaft auf Israel damit womöglich
ein weiterer Grenzübergang ein
israelischer Grenzübergang geöffnet
werden kann mhm Frau ostera sie sind
selbst Jüdin und auch oft in Tel Aviv
was würden Sie sich denn von der
israelischen Regierung Wünschen an der
stelle ich finde dass wir immer nur auf
Israel schauen aber kein Wort Richtung
Hamas verlieren wir müssen auch schauen
dass Hamas die Raketen stoppen muss und
Geiseln freilassen muss ich finde das
ist auch eine Voraussetzung für die
Israel um überhaupt jetzt bereit zu sein
über weitere Schritte nachzudenken ich
glaube das ist sehr wichtig Herr Chat
wie blicken sie auf die aktuelle
Situation ich glaube es ganz wichtig
auch mal auf die israelische
Innenpolitik zu schauen da passieren
ganz unterschiedliche teils auch sehr
widersprüchliche Sachen beispielsweise
gab jetzt gab es jetzt auch
Demonstration seitens der Angehörigen
der entführten die sich auch nicht
ausreichend vertreten sehen gerade von
der regier
netanahu insofern wächst da auch der
Druck etwas gerade im Bezug auf die
Problematik Freilassung der Geiseln zu
erreichen auf der anderen Seite hat das
israelische Militär ja seinen ersten
Teil der bundenoffensive auch schon auch
schon begonnen und ich glaube die wollen
erstmal genug Zeit haben bis sie dort
diese Teilung des Gazastreifens in einen
Nord und Südteil so abgeschlossen haben
bevor sie sich darauf einlassen
irgendwelche Feuerpausen oder
Konzessionen einzugehen also Sie sie
können auch verstehen dass Israel sagt
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist weder
Feuerpause noch Waffenstillstand möglich
ich denke da gibt's einerseits die
militärische andererseits die politische
Dimension ich glaube die militärische
Dimension ist gerade mitten in so einer
Operation die wahrscheinlich im mehreren
Phasen geplant ist die politische Arena
da ist der da ist der Druck noch höher
würde ich fast sagen
weil eben auch vom wichtigsten
Verbündeten den USA dort deutlicher
Druck aus noch ausgeübt wird der auch
noch mal steigen wird nicht nur was den
Gasastreifen anbetrifft sondern da
kommen wir vielleicht auch später noch
drauf was vielleicht sogar noch viel
wichtiger ist langfristiger was die
Situation im Westjordanland und
vielleicht auch in Ostjerusalem da
sprechen wir sprechen wir dann auf auf
jeden Fall später noch drüber Herr
Bickel wie ist ihre Einschätzung auch so
ähnlich also dass man zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht Feuerpause oder
Waffenstillstand erreichen kann oder es
ist gut dass Außenminister blinken in
der Region ist er trifft jetzt ab hat
gestern die Kollegen aus Saudi-Arabien
den vereinigten Arabien Ägypten und
Jordanien getroffen also
friedenspartnern Israels und der Versuch
auf eine Feuerpause hinzuwirken läuft
ich denke das wird in den nächsten Tagen
auch kommen aber die Frage dass der
Beschuss der Hamas auch gestoppt werden
muss um so eine Feuerpause für die
Israelis sicher zu machen der ist
wichtig zu diesem Moment ja also dann
hier an der Stelle ähm Übereinstimmung
ähm lassen sie uns vielleicht einmal auf
eine Karte der Region gucken ähm es gibt
ja an Israel angrenzend einige
Nachbarstaaten die auch keine unwichtige
Rolle spielen an der Stelle wir sehen
z.B im Norden Libanon
im
Osten Syrien und Jordanien im Westen
Ägypten lassen Sie uns kurz auf den
Libanon gucken da gibt's ja auch
Gefechte an der israelischen Nordgrenze
auch dort hat sich die Lage zugespitzt
am Freitag äußerte sich der
hisbollahchef das ist eine Gruppe im
Libanon die an dieser Stelle mit der
Hamas im Gazastreifen paktiert Hassan
nasralla heißt der Hisbollah Chef und er
hat sich zum ersten Mal seit
Kriegsbeginn öffentlich geäußert und hat
die Angriffe auf Israel durch die Hamas
gelobt und er hat vor allem skizziert
wie es möglicherweise in Zukunft
weitergehen könnte in dem
Konflikt alle Optionen der libanesischen
Front sind offen alle Möglichkeiten
könnten eintreten und wir sind bereit
sie einzusetzen wann immer wir sie
brauchen
also nasralla lässt offen ob es auch aus
der Nordgrenze aus dem Libanon jetzt
Angriffe auf Israel verstärkte Angriffe
auf Israel geben könnte Frau saubrei wie
bewerten Sie diese Einlassung das ist ja
so die Gefahr des zweif frontenkriegs
den man schon öfter skizziert hat ja mit
dem Israel auch Erfahrung hat sehr
schlechte und also die Rede wurde sehr
groß erwartet und ist dann ein bisschen
hinter den Erwartungen zurü
zurückgeblieben glücklicherweise weil
eben kein Einsatz am Boden im Norden
Israels angekündigt wurde sondern nur
diese drohen in den Raum gestellt wurde
ja könnte kommen Israel ist auf jeden
Fall vorbereitet hat die entsprechenden
Gebiete evakuiert ist mit Luftabwehr
vorbereitet die Amerikaner haben zwei
Schiffe in das Mittelmeer verlegt um
genau das zu verhindern um zu
signalisieren wenn ihr von Norden jetzt
wirklich am Boden auch Israel angreift
Luftangriffe gibt es ja auch
Raketenbeschuss aus dem Norden aber wenn
ihr jetzt wirklich Kriegshandlung auf
dem Boden vornehmt dann greifen wir ein
das ist sozusagen das Signal der
Amerikaner und im Moment gehen die
meisten Sicherheitsexperten mit denen
wir gesprochen haben in den letzten
Tagen eigentlich davon aus dass es
erstmal nicht dazu kommt sondern dass
ähm hebollah sich am Rande dieser
Drohung bewegt auch um an Iran den
großen Unterstützer dieser
Terrororganisation zu signalisieren ja
wir machen so ungefähr was ihr gerne
wollt was äh wir machen ähm aber wir
gehen diesen letzten Schritt nicht um
eben die Eskalation vor der sie selber
auch sich fürchten zu vermeiden Sie
haben ja gerade beschrieben dass da auch
der der Druck der USA im Moment eine
sehr wichtige Rolle spielt nun hat
nasralla den USA vorgeworfen die
Verantwortung für den Konflikt zu tragen
israel sei ein ausführendes Instrument
könnte denn die Eskalation trotzdem in
eine Art stellver Stellvertreterkrieg
münden also an dieser Stelle die USA die
ja immer an der Seite Israels standen
der stellvertr der Stellvertreterkrieg
findet schon statt die hisboll führt
stellvertretend für Iran gegen Israel
einen Krieg den Iran nicht direkt gegen
die USA führen will drum ist es ein
Stellvertreterkrieg aber die positive
Nachricht der Rede hisbollas von
nasralla ist tatsächlich gesagt zu haben
wir eskalieren an dieser Stelle nicht
weiter aber man darf nicht vergessen
dass die hisbolla seit 30 Tagen seit dem
8 Oktober jeden Tag israelische
Stellungen beschießt und auf beiden
Seiten der Grenze sind 10ta000ende
Zivilisten evakuiert das ist ein Krieg
der schon stattfindet mhm ähm vielleicht
gucken wir jetzt auf den Iran den haben
sie ja auch gerade schon angesprochen
und da möchte ich gerne noch mal auf
eine Karte gehen damit wir alle wissen
worüber wir sprechen es ist eine etwas
größere Karte wo man noch mal die
Situation Israels sieht die vier
anreiner haben wir ja gerade schon
gesehen das ist jetzt ein bisschen
größerer Blick also östlich von
Jordanien der Irak und dahinter noch der
Iran und am im südlichen Zipfel unserer
Karte der Jemen der äh auch mit dem Iran
verbündet ist an der Stelle es ist alles
sehr kompliziert in der Mitte sitzt
Saudi-Arabien äh die auch äh eine
mögliche Vermittlerrolle haben könnten
eher auf äh seitens Seiten der USA
stehen aber auch da gerade interessante
Annäherung möglicherweise mit Iran
stattfinden könnte sie sehen es ist
alles sehr komplex und wir wollen jetzt
mal drauf schauen welche regionalen aber
auch internationalen Mächte beeinflussen
denn den Konflikt und könnten ihn vor
allem in eine
deeskalierende Richtung drehen der Iran
Frau ostera der unterstützt die Hamas
und die hbolla seit vielen Jahren mit
Waffen und Geld das haben wir gerade
hier auch schon angedeutet welche
Interessen hat denn der Iran und was tut
er im Moment also der hisbolla Führer
hat ja explizit gesagt wir haben das
alles alleine gemacht die Hamas hat das
alles alleine gemacht Iran hatte da
seine Finger nicht im Spiel wie sehen
Sie die Position von Iran an der Stelle
also wir wissen schon dass Iran auch
Hamas und Hisbollah mit noh
sozusagen versorgt nicht nur militärisch
und finanziell und wir wissen dass vor
diesem Überfall auf Israel s Massaker
Kämpfer von Hamas vom Iran trainiert
worden sind also das dass Iran nichts
damit zu tun
hat möchte ich nicht
glauben die Sache ist aber dass Iran
glaube ich momentan nicht nicht an einer
größeren
Eskalation interessiert ist aus
verschiedenen Gründen erstmal nehmen wir
an dass Hamas nach diese nach diesem
Krieg militärisch geschlagen ist in
Gazastreifen das heißt der Iran verliert
somit ein Proxy in der Region und kann
nicht auch noch auf hiszbollah
verzichten obwohl die Raketen 150
Raketen von Hisbollah positioniert sind
Richtung Israel aber das wäre ein
Selbstmord weil genauso wie sie das
richtig gesagt haben zwei
flugzeugsträger sin vor der Küste
Libanons schon positioniert und ähm ich
glaube dass Iran nicht will dass der
Krieg sozusagen an seine Grenzen kommt
weil es inen ihnen sehr bewusst ist dass
sie Amerikanern und Israelis militärisch
unterlegen sind und dann muss man auch
noch sagen dass der Iran innenpolitisch
total instabil ist momentan wir hatten
die größte politische Krise seit der
Entstehung der Islamischen Republik 1979
nämlich die
fraulebenfiheitbewegung und ähm wir
haben eine sozioökonomische Krise im
Iran also die Islamische Republik ist
nicht mal in der Lage für die
Grundbedürfnisse der Menschen im Iran zu
sorgen wir haben eine massive
Umweltkrise im Iran das heißt ähm auch
laut Umfragen renommierte Umfragen sind
über 80% der Menschen im Iran gegen die
islamische Republik der Iran ist nicht
in der Lage diese Menschen dazu zu
bewegen für Sie an die Front zu gehen
und ähm außerdem ähm ich finde dass der
Iran eigentlich momentan auch der Sieger
dieser Situation ist
weil sie sehr erfolgreich von dieser
Frau lebenfreiheitbwegung abgelenkt
haben die Ölpreise sind sehr hoch sie
profitieren massiv dran sie konnten sehr
erfolgreich die Gespräche z.B zwischen
Israel und Saudi-Arabien sabotieren für
den Moment und auf die Ukraine schaut
auch niemand mehr und Russland ist ein
größer verbundeter von Iran und Iran ist
das einzige Land äh das Waffen Munition
und Drohnen an Russland verkauft und
auch daran massiv verdient deswegen
glaube ich nicht dass sie an einer
größeren Eskalation momental
interessiert genau also im Moment
glauben sie auch aufgrund der
innenpolitischen sorgen Irans und weil
viele Ziele jetzt quasi schon erreicht
sind sich doch erstmal weiter
zurückhalten könnte je nachdem wie es im
gaserstreifen weitergeht natürlich kann
man es nie sagen das kann immer
eskalieren aber trotzdem ist Iran
natürlich ein ganz ganz wichtiger Player
an der stelle ich möchte Stefan Geier
hier zitieren der hat auf X ehemals
Twitter geschrieben gibt es einen Hebel
der gleichzeitig auf die Hamas und den
Iran einwirkt Herr chattaj was könnte
das sein wenn es einen solchen Hebel
gäbe vielleicht kurz dazu auch noch mal
einer dieser versteckten Nachrichten
dieser codierten Nachrichten in der Rede
von Hassan nasralla das war im Prinzip
so ein eine nächste Fristsetzung das man
hat sich ja trotzdem alle Optionen
vorbehalten die die message dort ist wir
schauen noch mal wie das da weitergeht
in Gaza aber auch an anderen Orten z.B
westjorderalland vor allen Ding aus
Jerusalem und das könnte tatsächlich
dann noch mal was ändern also wir halten
für den Moment die Füße still bzw lassen
das auf einer bestimmten
Eskalationsstufe was jetzt
Einflussmöglichkeiten Hebel anbetrifft
hat man in den letzten Wochen glaube ich
ein startat gesehen der sich wieder ganz
nach oben
katapultiert hat in Sachen Diplomatie
und das ist Katar das ist innerhalb der
ganzen Region auch innerhalb der ganzen
Golfstaaten der einzige Staat der ja
auch Verbindung unter anderem hat mit
mit den Taliban mit mit Hamas
die natürlich argumentieren weil wir
diese Verbindungen halten können wir im
Zweifelsfall auch z.B limitierte geiself
Freilassung erreichen tatsächlich die
geiselfreilassung die bis jetzt
stattgefunden haben haben auch unter
Vermittlung der Hamas stattgefunden ein
anderer Akteur der sich so ein bisschen
Poltern von draußen reinbringen kann
ganz kurz noch mal wer die Türkei
Erdogan möchte dringendst als als als
ein wichtiger Vermittler wahrgenommen
werden hat gestern noch mal gesagt dass
die Türkei sich als garantiemacht für
Gaza empfieht ist aber bislang völlig
außen vor ja genau sie haben gerade
schon zwei weitere interessante Player
genannt also die Qatar und die Türkei
ich möchte einmal ganz kurz noch beim
Iran bleiben es gibt ja die sogenannte
Achse des Widerstands um jetzt auch noch
mal komplizierter zu machen angeführt
und finanziert vom Iran gehört unter
anderem Syrien dazu die hisbolla im
Libanon und die Hammers im gazaastreifen
m Herr Bickel haben Sie den Eindruck
genau ich habe die huti Rebellen im jem
vergessen die haben wir eben schon auf
der Karte gesehen haben sie die den
Eindruck dass die Achse des Widerstands
obwohl Iran eigentlich im Moment andere
Probleme hat jetzt doch offensiver
agiert als das früher der Fall war und
wenn ja woher kommt das und wo könnte
das noch hinführen ich glaube die Achse
des Widerstands ist sozusagen auf dem
Höhepunkt ihrer Macht in diesem Moment
dieser Überfall auf Südisrael das
brutale Massaker mit 1300 Toten zeigt
das da gab es nie eine Abwendung von
Iran die das verurteilt hätte der Iran
steht hinter der Hamas Qatar hat eine
vermittlernde Rolle zurzeit inner als
der Iran natürlich der Israel als
totfeind sieht wo das hinführen könnte
ist ein möglicher fün frontenkrieg wobei
nicht alle Fronten ähnlich intensiv
bespielt werden beschossen bekämpft
werden aber sie haben die hutis genannt
das ist eine neue Dimension der Achse
des Widerstands die gab's vor 10 Jahren
nicht dass aus dem Jemen aus 2000 km
Entfernung Raketen nach Israel
abgeschossen werden können das zeigt wie
stark die Achse des Widerstands zurzeit
ist das ist tatsächlich jetzt neu an der
Stelle
vielleicht an Frau Sauerbrei noch diese
Frage auf auch von Twitter warum nimmt
kein arabisches Land Palästinenser auf
wie viel finanzielle aber auch
humanitäre Hilfe leisten eigentlich
diese arabischen Länder auch das könnte
ja sage ich mal den den Druck auf die
katastrophale Situation im Gazastreifen
jetzt lindern warum geschieht da so
wenig ja
die arabischen Nachbarstaaten haben zwar
immer in ihren Worten sehr stark die
Palästinenser unterstützt und müssen das
auch tun weil es große Sympathie in
vielen dieser Länder in der Bevölkerung
gibt für die Sache der Palästinenser für
einen palästinensischen Staaten
natürlich auch die humanitäre Lage aber
politisch haben sie sich tatsächlich ja
schon lange über über Jahrzehnte nicht
richtig eingesetzt für einen
palästinensischen Staat für eine
diplomatische Friedenslösung
humanitär schon in Teilen aber damit
sind auch in den Nachbarstaaten ganz
viele Ängste verbunden vor allen Dingen
Ägypten also Ägypten ist wirklich
beinenht jetzt sind einige
Doppelstaatler durften jetzt über diesen
einen grenzübergangerfach dann
dass den Gazastreifen verlassen aber
Leute die sagen nur Palästinenser sind
keine ausländischen Pässe zusätzlich
haben sind weiterhin darin gefangen und
das liegt auch daran dass Ägypten nicht
möchte dass die Palästinenser nach
Ägypten kommen man hat einerseits selber
Sicherheitsbedenken man möchte diese ja
insgesamt 2,2 Millionen Menschen oder
hunderttausende nicht versorgen man hat
den Sinai im Prinzip auch in Teilen
entvölkert um so eine Art Pufferzone zu
schaffen und bei all diesen Dingen
möchte man gerne bleiben und dann gibt's
natürlich bedenken auch
dass es auch eine israelische Strategie
sein könnte oder diese Vermutung gibt es
in vielen arabischen Ländern dass man
jetzt den Gasastreifen systematisch
entvölkert um
sozusagen das das Problem aus
israelischer Sicht ein für alle Mal
loszuwerden und auch da sagt Ägypten
sagen andere arabische Staaten das
lassen wir nicht zu die Bevölkerung muss
da bleiben um irend weiterhin die
Möglichkeit eines palästinensischen
Staates offen
zuuhalten es gibt ja tatsächlich so ein
Geheimpapier angeblich der israelischen
Regierung das sagt
also ich weiß nicht wer es verfasst
haben soll aber das sagt eben also am
schönsten wer es wenn man den
Gasastreifen quasi auf die Sinai
Halbinsel hin entvölkern kann es gibt
Strömungen wissen wir rechtsextreme
Strömungen innerhalb der jetzigen
israelischen Regierung aber ich glaube
nicht dass die Israelis die
Friedensgespräche vor allem mit
arabischen Ländern damit aufs Spiel
setzen damit wäre es wirklich vorbei
auch die Beziehungen zu Amerika auch der
Rest der Welt eigentlich äh damit ja
würde ich mal sagen riskiert deswegen
glaube ich das eher nicht ich glaube ähm
ja das Ägypten das einfach nicht machen
will weil sie Sicherheitsbedenken haben
und sich nicht darum kümmern wollen ja
vielleicht kurz da einhakend ä ich
glaube die Angst bei vielen
Palästinensern oder auch in der Region
ist dass das eben doch passiert weil
die Regierung Netanyahu ja erpressbar
ist politisch abpressbar von einer ganz
kleinen radikalen Gruppe das sind ja
auch Parteien die haben sich erst
zusammen geschlossen sind so überhaupt
erst in die Knesset gekommen die haben
für sich vielleicht 1 2% bei den Wahlen
bekommen haben aber einen unglaublichen
Einfluss und noch sehr sehr mächtige
Ämter bekommen
aus palästinensischer Sicht läuft seit
Anfang dieses Jahres seit sich die
Regierung konstituiert hat der nächste
Schritt in der Annektion des
Westjordanlands und man hat auch Angst
davor was mit mit dem Tempelberg z.B
passiert und wenn man jetzt
dort beobachtet was in Gaza ganz offen
jetzt diskutiert wird nämlich die
Vertreibung von über Menschen äh ist es
nur eine Bestätigung dieser Ängste auch
sehr tiefliegende Traumata
von vertreibungserfahrung 48 und 67 die
jetzt wiederkommen und man sieht keine
Versicherung z.B vom Regierungschef der
sagt dass was meine Minister dort auf X
Twitter dort von sich geben das ist
jetzt nicht unsere Position sondern man
lässt das so im Raum stehen und ich
glaube da wä es
unfassbar wichtig dass D mal ein klares
Statement äh kommt vor allen Dingen um
halt dem so ein bisschen den Wind aus
den we Segen zu nehmen weil ansonsten
gibt's dort auch keinerlei Fortschritte
sehen sie auch ja ich also ich würde
noch mal verstcken was fr osterer gesagt
hat ich glaube dass die Amerikaner als
ja auch einer der wichtigsten Geldgeber
Israels jetzt ist ja ein weiteres
Milliardenpaket auch im Kongress
vorgesehen Militärhilfe dass sie es
zulassen würden also beiden steht
einfach innenpolitisch immer stärker
unter Druck eben wegen der humanitären
Notlage auch wegen der Angst um
Vertreibung von Palästinenser aus dem
gazaastreifen es gibt er verliert die
Zustimmung der arabisch-amerikanischen
Bevölkerung in Amerika wird ja nächstes
Jahr gewählt er verliert die Zustimmung
gerade der jüngeren Amerikaner und auch
vieler jüngerer Abgeordneter in seiner
eigenen Partei die teilweise selber
biograhischen Hintergrund in der Region
haben die sehr stark darin sind auch
Widerstand dagegen zu mobilisieren also
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es
dafür von amerikanischer Seite hinter
den Kulissen ein Okay geben würde aber
die Ängste sind natürlich da klar sind
die Ängste da und man muss auch sagen 48
gab es nicht nur Vertreibungen sondern
es waren auch Kriegsflüchtlinge Menschen
die auf dem Flucht waren und dazu muss
man sagen wir müssen abwarten was mit
der Regierung Netanyahu passiert ich
führe sehr viele Gespräche mit meiner
Familie mit meinen Bekannten und
Freunden vor Ort und auch andere
Menschen die ich kennengelernt habe
journalistisch äh sie sagen alle wenn
dieser Krieg vorbei ist kümmern wir uns
um die Regierung und die waren ja auch 9
Monate lang jeden Samstag auf der Straße
also das darf man nicht vergessen Israel
ist eine lebendige Demokratie und ich
habe sehr viel Hoffnung dass die
Menschen wirklich ähm ja sich um diese
Regierung auch wirklich kümmern nach dem
vielleicht an der Stelle danke auch noch
mal für diesen innenpolitischen Blick
nach Israel wir waren ja gerade dabei zu
gucken welche Länder Nachbarn oder
internationale Mächte können denn jetzt
deeskalieren oder sogar befrieden sie
haben
Herr chatj gerade Qatar angesprochen das
ist in sofern ein hochinteressantes Land
weil dort tatsächlich ja der der
politische Arm der Hamas auch ein Büro
unterhält und möglicherweise jetzt die
Befreiung der Geiseln die schon
stattgefunden hat auch tatsächlich durch
Vermittlung von Qatar mit der Hamas
stattgefunden hat m liegt der Schlüssel
zu einer sogar größeren Lösung also
jetzt nicht nur die Geiseln sondern
möglicherweise eine Befriedung auch bei
Qatar was könnten die für eine Rolle
spielen Herr Bickel das kommt drauf an
ob Sie für eine Befriedung Gazas eine
Nachkriegsordnung in Gaza gebraucht
werden oder ob wir uns eine
gesamtregionale Lösung anschauen und
kurz mittelfristig mit einer
Nachkriegsordnung auf Gaza wird es Qatar
brauchen allein finanziell in den
letzten Jahren sind Milliarden an Dollar
nach Gaza von Qatar gekommen und die
Israelis hatten aber immer einen sehr
genauen Blick wohin das Geld geht der
Vorwurf an Qatar der Hamas Unterschlupf
zu bieten ist richtig zugleich haben die
Israelis sich jeden Dollar angeschaut
der von Katar in den Gazastreifen kam
deshalb wird Qatar weiter gebraucht
werden aber ich glaube es werden auch
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
Ägypten und Jordanien als die alten
friedensmächte und möglicherweise
Marokko gebraucht auch marokko hat vor 3
Jahren Frieden mit Israel geschlossen
und ich glaube diese neuen Partner
Israels werden für eine
Nachkriegsordnung entscheidend sein die
Europäische Union fällt als Akteur Weg
der Golfkooperationsrat mit
Saudi-Arabien mit den Emiraten mit Katar
könnte ein schlüsselakteur sein für eine
politische Lösung die die Länder die sie
jetzt genannt haben sind ja eher
tatsächlich angenähert an an Israel an
der Stelle
die Frage ist ja wer hat denn einen
Draht zur Hamas ne also die die andere
Seite muss ja an dieser Stelle auch mit
einbezogen werden Qatar haben sie gerade
beschrieben sie haben auch schon die
Türkei angesprochen die jetzt eine
interessante Positionierung vorgenommen
hat
äh erdogan hat ja sehr klar sich auf die
Seite da äh des palästinensischen
Befreiungskampfes gestellt wie
beurteilen Sie das also ist das von
erdoan ernst gemeint im Sinne von ich
kann da vermitteln oder ist es einfach
ein taktisches Spielchen seinerseits
beides also erdogan hat ein sehr feines
Gespür wo man als Populist Punkte
sammeln kann gerade natürlich nachdem
man gerade so ganz knapp erst nur im Amt
bestätigt wurde es war ja die größte
Legitimationskrise
Erdogans bis jetzt und er sieht
natürlich die Möglichkeit
sich zu einem Führer in der islamischen
Welt als der sich ja auch sieht
hochzuschwingen und sich auch ein
bisschen abzusetzen besonders natürlich
von von der Position einiger Golfstaaten
gerade wir haben gerade die Emirate
genannt die irgendwie gar nicht so
öffentlich auftreten wollen
aber durchaus auch von Qatar die ja sich
vor allen Dingen als seriöse
Unterhändler empfehlen und gleichzeitig
ja aber auch z.B zeigen dass der Weg den
Saudi-Arabien
unmittelbar jetzt eingeschlagen hätte
oder den auch die Emirate eingeschlagen
hat halt nicht der Weg ist den sie gehen
ich glaube was es bei Katar noch mal
ganz wichtig ist wir erleben auch gerade
wieder so eine Renaissance von
aljasira so wie das schon vor 10 20
Jahren so war aljasira ist wirklich der
Sender der aus Sicht vieler Menschen in
der Region als einziger ihre Perspektive
wiedergibt und der eben auch so ein
Stück Empathie auch zeigt das was wird
bei ganz vielen Menschen in der Region
vermissen das gerade auf Seiten der
Golfstaaten
eine Empathie für die palästinensische
Sache für palästinensische Zivilisten
aljasira hat ja auch teilweise eben auch
Journalisten dort verloren ist also auch
deswegen da sehr engagiert auch letztes
Jahr gab's ja die Journalistin Shirin
abuakle die getötet wurde das ist für
ganz viele Menschen ein ganz wichtiger
Fall gewesen das war ein Genin ne ganz
genau und ich glaube diese Perspektive
die müssen wir uns noch vor allem vor
Augen halten was sehen die Menschen was
ist Ihnen wichtig und wie glauben Sie
repräsentieren die Staaten auch auch so
ihre Gefühlslage bei Iran z.B ganz
spannend ich glaube ein Großteil der
iranischen Bevölkerung hat durchaus
Sympathie mit der palästinensischen
Zivilbevölkerung aber eben natürlich
keine große Liebe für das iranische
Regime und vor allen Dingen auch nicht
für das ganze Geld dass da seit den
letzten 10 15 Jahren Richtung Hamas und
des Boller abfließt vielleicht bleiben
wir bei der Türkei Frau Sauerbrei vor
allem also die Rolle als Vermittler ist
ja schon ernst zu nehmen deshalb ist
auch Anthony blinken ichtig jetzt auf
dem Weg in die Türkei nachdem er in
ramalla war
doch hat sich ja auch der türkische
Präsident sehr klar positioniert indem
er Israel als Kriegsverbrecher
bezeichnet hat also kann das gelingen
mit Erdogan und wenn ja in welcher Form
na ich würde sagen er hat sich dadurch
auch teilweise aus dem Spiel genommen
weil er eben nicht den palästinensischen
Freiheitskampf sondern die Verbrechen
der Hamas gerechtfertigt hat und das ist
was ganz anderes ohnehin es ist ja das
israelische Kriegsziel die die Hamas wie
es dann heißt mit der Wurzel auszureißen
aus dem Gazastreifen das heißt die Frage
ist sitzen die am Ende wenn Israel
erfolgreich ist überhaupt an einem
Verhandlungstisch oder sitzen da dann
nicht eher andere Vertreter der
Palästinenser die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde und wie würde dann
Erdogan vermitteln können in dieser Lage
wo er also eigentlich mit Israel jetzt
nicht mehr gesprächsfähig ist nachdem er
die Terroranschläge die 1400 Toten in
dieser Art und Weise relativiert hat ich
sehe tatsächlich eher die Amerikaner
weiterhin als die Macht die mit allen
Seiten am besten reden kann die auch
einfach die meisten Hebel in der Hand
hat durch die große Militärhilfe für die
Israelis
eben auch durch die Militärpräsenz in
der Region durch die vergleichsweise
guten Beziehung zu anderen Golfstaaten
ist wirklich noch mal so ein so eine Art
weltpolitikm der Amerikaner den wir da
jetzt sehen nachdem sie sich jahrelang
nicht um den den Kernkonflikt also den
israelisch-pästinensischen Konflikt
wirklich gekümmert haben
hören wir jetzt doch wieer von Joe Biden
wir sind für die zwei staatenlösung wir
wollen eine nachhaltige und
diplomatische Lösung ich denke da wird
sich Amerika jetzt sehr stark engagieren
als hätten wir es abgesprochen könnte
ich jetzt genau diesen ohon vom US
Außenminister einspielen weil wir wollen
ja jetzt auch gucken wie könnte es
möglicherweise eine Lösung geben hat
sich genau zu dieser Zukunft auch
geäußert wie aus seiner Sicht die Region
Israel und mit den Palästinensern
befriedet werden kann hören wir mal rein
die USA ist der
dass der beste Weg der einzige Weg die
zwei staatenlösung ist das ist der
einzige Garant für ein sicheres
jüdisches und demokratisches Israel und
ein Garant dafür dass die Palästinenser
ihre legitimen Bestrebung erfüllen im
einem eigenen Staat zu leben in Würde
und in Freiheit das ist die einzige
Möglichkeit um diesen Zyklus der Gewalt
endgültig zu
beenden das ist also die elle Position
der USA so klar ist das auch schon lange
nicht mehr ausgesprochen worden seitens
der USA Frau osterer wie realistisch ist
denn dieser Wunsch ich finde wir können
nicht nachhaltig über den Frieden in
Nahen Osten sprechen ohne über die Rolle
der Islamischen Republik Iran zu
sprechen das ist unmöglich nehmen wir an
wir haben jetzt ein super Konzept für
ein Zweistaatenlösung eine neue
funktionierende aber solange die
Islamische Republik an der Macht ist
gibt es kein Interesse daran dass dieser
Zweistaatenlösung funktioniert dass ein
jüdischen Staat gibt weil Zerstörung
Israels ist die Rhetorik der Islamischen
Republik um das vielleicht besser
aufzumachen die Islamische Republik ist
mehr oder weniger auf drei Grundpfeilern
gebaut das ist einmal die systematische
Unterdrückung der Frauen haben wir
gesehen letztes Jahr haben wir sehr viel
drüber gesprochen einmal die Feindschaft
mit Amerika einmal die Feindschaft von
Israel also diese retorik sagt wir wir
vernichten Israel und erobern alkurz
also
Jerusalem das heißt auch wenn Hamas
zerstört ist wenn wir jetzt eine
Superlösung gefunden haben solange die
islamischen Republik da ist wird es
Krieg gegen Israel geben und ich glaube
was wir brauchen ist endlich eine Wende
in unserer Außenpolitik gegenüber die
Islamische Republik wir haben eine
Beschwichtigungspolitik gehabt jahrelang
mit den Iranern und wir haben gesehen
dass so nicht weitergehen kann dass
jetzt durch ein Proxy der Islamischen
Republik ein riesen Massaker in Israel
auf israelischen Boden stattgefunden hat
niemand hat damit gerechnet und die Frau
lebenfiheitbewegung war die beste Chance
um diese Wende einzuleiten es ist immer
noch nicht spät aber leider haben wir
diesen besten Moment verpasst weil die
Forderungen der Menschen im Iran waren
klar die absolute Isolierung der
Islamischen Republik durch gezite S enen
die maelite durch Einstellung von JCP
Verhandlungen durch terrorlung der IRGC
das ist alles nicht geschen sie sagen
also solange es die ISL Islamische
Republik Iran in dieser Form gibt kann
es keinen Frieden zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern geben würden sie das so
teilen herrel zurück zu der Frage ob die
zwei Staaten Lösung der Weg ist das
hatten sie ja gefragt ich glaube die
internationale Gemeinschaft die
internationale Gemeinschaft immer wenn
sie ratlos ist packt sie die zwei
Staaten wieder aus die ist jetzt 30
Jahre alt ich glaube die müsste
modifiziert werden angesichts der
Situation in Gaza zu einer
dreistaatenlösung weil so wie man das
Westjordanland behandelt wird man Gaza
in Zukunft nicht behandeln können
insofern glaube ich nicht an die
Zweistaatenlösung glaube aber daran dass
ein diplomatischer Weg gefunden werden
muss Gaza eine Übergangslösung zu finden
mit internationaler Hilfe und ob der
Iran dabei eine Rolle spielen kann das
glaube ich derzeit nicht für diese
kurzfristige Lösung um Frieden im Nahen
Osten ein kollektives System kollektiver
Sicherheit zu schaffen wird es eines
Tages Iran und Saudi-Arabien Brau für
die größere die größere Perspektive
braucht es den Iran vielleicht noch mal
kurz dieser Axe des Widerstands ich sehe
das nicht so dass die jetzt auf der
Spitze der Stärke ist ganz im Gegenteil
wenn man sich mal anguckt was Iran und
vor allen auch seine Vasallen jetzt in
den letzten 10 15 Jahren gemacht haben
worauf die Konzentration lag diebollab
hat ist dem Assad regim zur Hilfe geeilt
ebenso wie
wie viele der irakischen Milizen im Irak
tut man immer noch so als wenn man dort
eine unterdrückte Minderheit ist obwohl
man de facto da seit fast 20 Jahren
eigentlich immer aner macht ist und das
Missmanagement der macht auch eine der
Grundlagen geschaffen hat aus dem der is
entstehen konnte im Jemen hat man ein
hat man einen einen Krieg vom Zaun
gebrochen mit einer Bewegung die an
keinerlei Stabilität und Fortschritt
interessiert ist und abgesehen von
diesen paar Raketen die man die man
glaube ich um mal ein Zeichen zu setzen
geschickt hat ist der Fokus da auch da
drauf
das eigene Land Z Grunde zu richten und
deswegen und in Iran hat man das das
haben wir schon gesagt ist der Fokus ja
auch sich an der Macht zu halten das ist
macht er halt aber Herr Chat wir waren
jetzt bei der zwei staatenlösung genau
ich wollte das nur darauf kurz antworten
das rondetre ist natürlich Israel als
Feindbild aber wenn man sich mal die
Praxis anguckt war das war das überhaupt
nicht der Fokus sondern vor allen Dingen
in anderen Ländern dort versuchen zu
regieren größtenteils zu scheitern und
gerade damit beschäftigt zu sein sich an
der Macht zu halten ja natürlich das ist
eine Strategie der Islamischen Republik
wie gesagt also wenn diese Feindschaft
mit Israel wegfällt fällt sozusagen die
Identität der Islamischen Republik Weg
deswegen sage ich auch die sind nicht an
großere Eskalationen interessiert aber
trotzdem werden sie immer wieder zündeln
in der in der Region also damit werden
sie nicht aufhören ich möchte gerne noch
wieder eine Stimme aus von den sozialen
Medien reinbringen auf xform alss
Twitter fragt jemand warum ist es
eigentlich bis jetzt unmöglich den
friedlichen Palästinensern ihren eigenen
souveränen Staat zu geben eine ganz
einfache Frage von Sauerbrei mit einer
wahrscheinlich nicht einfachen Antwort
na in Teilen hat man den friedlichen
palästinens oder die die man als
Vertreter der friedlichen Palästinenser
anerkannt hat also die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde ja
quasi staatlich
Verantwortung übertragen im
Westjordanland zumindest für soem
abgestufen System für einige Teile
dieser Region und Israel hat sich ja
auch zurückgezogen aus Gasa hat sagen
alle Siedler evakuiert 2005 schon und
hat gesagt ja gut dann macht mal dann
wurde gewählt und die Hamas kam an die
Macht und hat seitdem keine Wahlen mehr
an abgehalten und seitdem hat man wieder
in verschiedenen Eskalationsstufen mit
diesem Sicherheitsproblem zu tun und
jetzt müsste man halt unter wenn man zu
einer zweistaten Lösung will und da bin
ich bei Herrn bicke es muss da
wahrscheinlich Übergangsphasen geben
wieder einen verlässlichen Partner
finden und die sind im Moment Rah also
die Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde
selbst ist ist sehr schwach der der Chef
Mahmut ab bas den jetzt der den ja
blinken auch jetzt getroffen hat ist
sehr alt auch die
haben genau die Westjordanland regieren
auch die haben seit Jahren schon keine
Wahlen mehr abgehalten die sind sehr
schlecht legitimiert in der eigenen
Bevölkerung werden auch im gaserstreifen
nicht eben gut angesehen aber es ist im
Moment sozusagen das beste mit mit dem
man arbeiten kann vielleicht unter einer
anderen neuen Führung
ich glaube auch dass Frau oserer Recht
hat die extremistischen Kräfte haben
kein Interesse an einem Frieden und
deswegen haben wir sozusagen über den
ganzen Friedensprozess ja auch immer
wieder gesehen wenn wenn es mal so ein
bisschen nach den Oslo Abkommen dann so
auss als könnte es zu einer dauerhaften
Lösung kommen
kam dann doch eben war auch Teil der
extremistischen Gewalt dann die Ursache
dafür dass es irgendwie nicht
weitergingchenäte auf genau auf beiden
also vor allen Dingen Hamas und und
Unterstützung durch hbolla und Iran und
ich glaube jetzt besteht halt die Chance
wenn Israel das tatsächlich gelingt die
Heras entscheiden zu schwächen oder
sogar auszuschalten dass dann ein Faktor
wegfällt und dass man vielleicht dann
erstmal mit anderen Kräften in
verschiedenen Übergangslösungen arbeiten
kann vielleicht an der stelleel möchte
ich noch mal nachfragen was sie eben mit
mittelfristiger also jetzt was kann man
wenn wenn die milit Auseinandersetzung
aufhört was kann man tun haben sie
gesagt drei staatenlösung aber wir
müssen ja irgendwie mit dem Gasastreifen
und dem Westjordanland unterschiedlich
umgehen die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde die das Westjordanland
aktuell regiert sind sie da auch der
Meinung die kann nicht einfach auch den
gazerastreifen jetzt wieder übernehmen
was wäre denn da ein realistisches
Szenario ich bin der Meinung dass sie
den gazerastreifen so nicht übernehmen
kann weil sie ja auch an völliger
Glaubwürdigkeit fehlt seitens der
Bevölkerung Abbas und seine äh
Mitstreiter sind korrupt das ist
nachgewiesen und im Gaza sehnt man sich
nach der Hamas nicht nach einer
korrupten palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde dennoch wird die
internationale Gemeinschaft nicht darum
herumkommen lokale Kräfte örtliche
notablen im Gazastreifen zu finden die
diesen politischen Übergang mitgestaltet
und die Hauptaufgabe für eine
Nachkriegsordnung wird ja auch
wirtschaftlicher Wiederaufbau humanitäre
Versorgung sein drum ist der Begriff
dreistaatenlösung etwas überspitzt weil
Gaza wird kein eigenständiger Staat
werden aber wenn man die alte Idee der
Osloer Verträge ein israelischer Staat
der existiert und ein palästinensischer
mit nennenswerten Vollmachten bekommen
will dann muss man mit Gaza künftig
anders umgehen als das 1993 vorgesehen
war sie haben gerade gesagt die
internationale Gemeinschaft muss dann
auch vor Ort Player finden die da
vielleicht dann z.B den Gazastreifen
unter ihre Kontrolle bringen könnten wer
könnte das sein wie könnte das aussehen
können z.B der Emiraten sein Marokko
also Staaten die Israel sozusagen
wohlgesonnen sind aber da muss man sich
auch fragen das muss halt auch ähm ja
m ein Armee oder ja ein Militär sein der
bereit ist auch durchzugreifen weil wie
wenn wieder Aufstände gibt von
extremistischen Gruppen ob sich das
jemand jetzt momentan antun will das ist
die Frage mm verstehe ähm also wir haben
glaube ich einen guten Überblick darüber
bekommen wie komplex und differenziert
die Lage zu betrachten ist am ehsten
habe ich jetzt hier rausgehört
mittelfristig wäre eine Lösung dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft mit
arabischen Verbündeten erstmal eine
Deeskalation im gaserstreifen versucht
vielleicht ist das der nächste Schritt
und
dreist staten zweiaaten Lösung oder was
auch immer werden wir sicherlich noch
viele Sendungen zu machen zu diesem
Thema was uns alle noch auch sehr sehr
lange beschäftigen wird das war der
presseclclub hier im ersten für heute es
geht weiter mit dem europamagazin das
befasst sich auch mit dem Nahostkonflikt
und unter anderem mit der Rolle
Russlands die Putin aktuell spielt oder
die Interessen die Putin dort
möglicherweise haben könnte auf phöniix
WDR V und in den sozialen Netzwerken
folgt jetzt Presseclub nachgefragt in
jedem Fall wünsche ich Ihnen noch einen
guten Sonntag bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
und da sind wir wieder mit presseclclub
nachgefragt auf phöniix WDR5 und in den
sozialen Netzwerken unser Thema Ausweg
gesucht wie ist der Nahe Osten zu retten
und ich möchte als ersten Fragenden in
die Runde thomas Schneider aus
Saarbrücken bitten guten
Tag ja guten
Tag sie sind dran sie können jetzt an
die Runde Ihre Frage stellen Herr
Schneider ja es ist eigentlich ihr eine
Anmerkung und die die hat die Dame der
der Zeit mir fast vorweggenommen also
ich habe den starken Eindruck dass die
tatsächlichen Feinde der friedliebenden
Palästinenser weder in Jerusalem noch in
telaviv sitzen sondern in
Kommandozentralen dieser Mörderbanden in
Gaza islamischer Jihad und Hamas und in
den arabischen Bruderstaaten den viel
geliebten
ich glaube beide beide Seiten beide
Parteien wollen einfach dass dieses Leid
ewig weitergeht um einen Stachel im
Fleisch Israels zu haben würden die
palästinen das irgendwie schaff durch
Zauberkraft oder was auch immer
friedlich für ihre Anliegen zu
demonstrieren
bin ich der Meinung gerade angesichts
der israelischen Regierung zur Zeit an
der sehr viel kritikwürdiges ist sehr
viel kritikwürdiges ist dass sie das
innerhalb von Jahren erreichen würden
sie haben gerade gesagt durch
Zauber ja ich meine ich weiß nicht wie
sich ich gehe einfach davon aus dass es
viele friedliebende Palästinenser gibt
wie können sich solche Menschen gegen
gegen solche Mistkerle wie Hamas und
islamischer Jihad äh eine Stimme
verschaffen das scheint mir fast
unmöglich ja Herr Schneider danke für
Ihre Anmerkung die ja doch auch eine
Frage beinhaltete und Frau saubrei kann
vielleicht noch weiter ausführen sie
haben sich ja auf ihn ja ich fand es
interessant dass es
gerade bis in die letzten Tage vor dem
Krieg eine Untersuchung durchgeführt
wurden von der Princeton University im
Gazastreifen wo die Leute befragt wurden
wenn sie denn wählen würden wenn wenn
jetzt Wahlen wären und wie es um das
Vertrauen in die Hamas Regierung steht
und dabei ist rausgekommen dass das
Vertrauen sehr sehr gering ist also 44%
der Leute haben gesagt wir trauen dieser
Regierung überhaupt nicht weitere
irgendwas 20% haben gesagt wir trauen
ihr nur sehr wenig und wenn man fragt
wen würden Sie denn wählen dann
schneiden sowohl die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde also Abbas als auch der
politische Führer der Hamas sehr
schlecht dabei ab das heißt es gibt eine
große Gruppe von Leuten die sich
eigentlich was ganz anderes wünschen
dort wie man das jetzt umsetzt ob man da
irgendwann Wahlen abhält ob die diese
Leute dann tatsächlich eine andere
Regierung wählen und und wer dann auch
die Kandidaten sind darüber haben wir ja
schon gesprochen wie schwierig das ist
da Vertreter zu finden aber es es gibt
diese Menschen also es gab auch vor ein
paar Monaten Umfrage vom
palästinensischen Institut wer die
Favoriten für die Präsidentschaftswahlen
wären die ja seit 2009 nicht
durchgeführt werden der der Gewinner
dort der sitzt aber auch seit fast 20
Jahren im Gefängnis auch ein Name den
der Vieren glaube ich nicht so viel sagt
maruan Rui ist aber jemand der eben
nicht diesen Markel hat den sowohl Hamas
als auch ver gr im Gefängnis nur damit
wir
alle eigentlich die größte Angst der
Hamas inpolitisch ist ja dass sie
genauso gesehen wird wie die fatach
nämlich ein Haufen von eigentlich so
korrupten alten Männern der bevor wir
hier jetzt wieder unter uns diskutieren
sorry wir sind in der viertel Stunde wo
wir ganz möglichst viele Menschen dran
nehmen wollen aber sie kommen auch
gleich noch mal zu Wort ich möchte
erstmal weiter nach Münster zu Nelson da
Silva hallo und ihre Frage
bitte ein Wunders ein wunderschönen
guten Tag in die Runde meine Frage ist
wie folgt wenn dieser brutale Krieg
irgendwann einmal
endet mit wem sollte die
palästinensische Seite denn dann einen
dauerhaften Frieden und eine zwei
Staaten
aus Lösung aushandeln etwa mit solchen
Ministern wie it Ben die auf jeden Fall
rechtsradikal sind und he Terroristen
sind wer soll dort dann der
Ansprechpartner sein und diese Regierung
ändert sich schon seit fast zwei Dekaden
nicht also glaube ich auch nicht daran
dass sie israelisch das Volk von sich
aus das lösen wird ja danke Herr da
Silva und ich habe sie ja eben nicht
dran genommen Frau Oster bitte ja das
habe ich ja schon vorhin auch
angesprochen also erstmal zwei Dekaden
haben wir diese Regierung nicht das
stimmt so nicht wer und Leute wie modrd
die sind seit kurzem erst an der Macht
leider und wie gesagt also die man hat
ja gesehen diese lebendige
Demonstrationen seit 9un Monaten auf den
Straßen in Israel überall und ähm ich
glaube die gehen auch weiter nach dem
Krieg und ich habe sehr viel Hoffnung
dass die Menschen in Israel
mit dieser Regierung abrechnen also das
ist was ich zumindest aus Israel höre
dass sie das nicht hinnehmen man muss
auch noch sagen ähm das Vertrauen in
Netanyahu ist weiterhin ähm erschüttert
auch in Schichten die ihn gewählt haben
äh weil man gesehen hat dass er nicht in
der Lage war für die Sicherheit der
Menschen in Israel zu
sorgen es gibt ja ähm Unterlagen die
belegen dass die ähm ägyptische dass der
ägyptische Geheimdienst ihn gewarnt hat
vor einem möglichen Anschlag und er
bestreitet das und es gibt auch noch
Minister von ihm die ihn warnen wollten
die haben die wollten mit ihm sprechen
über mögliche Risiko äh
Sicherheitsrisiken und er hat diese
Gespräche auch abgelehnt also ich glaube
er hat nach diesem Krieg keine Chance an
der Macht zu bleiben vielleicht ganz
kurz zu israelischen Regierung die die
haben sich auch schon als sehr flexibel
erwiesen wenn man sich überlegt die
Vorgängerregierung bevor jetzt nanyu an
die Macht gekommen ist war eine sehr
bunte Koalition da waren da waren
siedlervertreter drin da waren auch
gemäßigte Islamisten drin also insofern
das ist so ein bisschen der Charakter
dieses neuen klein Parteien System man
hat nicht mehr diese Verhältnisse wie
früher wo es auch ein paar große gibt
die Arbeiterpartei ist so ein bisschen
verschwunden war früher ein ganz großer
Treiber auch
der Friedens Friedensgespräche mit mit
Rabin und diesen ganzen Leuten die ist
so nicht mehr da vielleicht eine Sache
noch wer sowas auch verhandeln kann sind
natürlich auch die Leute aus dem geheim
und Sicherheitsapparat die Osloer
Abkommen haben das politische und das
diplomatische ja auch ein bisschen
getrennt wenn man sich mal anguckt wo
die kritischen Stimmen zu Besatz und
Frieden derzeit herkommt s das ganz oft
ehemalige Leiter von schinbet
mossart oder auch aus der Armee also ich
find das sind Leute die signalisieren
hey wir haben hier praktische Erfahrung
wir haben h Kontakte vor Ort auch mit
palästinensischer Seite wir haben Jahre
Erfahrung in der sicherheitskooperation
auf die Leute sollte man zugehen gab ja
auch große Protest gegen netan ja
richtig genau richtig so wir wollen aber
noch jemanden hören der sich hier auch
gemeldet hat in der Leitung und zwar
Anja Gronau aus Berlin hallo ja hallo
guten Tag danke dass ich drankommen kann
für mich ist im Moment die Situation so
dass ich denke alle die Weltgemeinschaft
muss sich jetzt zusammenschließen um da
wirklich eine Lösung her zufüh
herbeizuführen also letztendlich geht es
ja alles zurück auf diesen Teilungsplan
181 die unresolution von
1947 und die Vereinten Nationen haben es
nicht geschafft diese Idee zur gegen zum
gegenseitigen Vorteil also für die
Palästinenser und die jüdische
Bevölkerung dort oder später Israel zu
moderieren und zu begleiten s dass diese
Idee von dem Teilungsplan auch wirklich
fruchtbar für alle wird und inzwischen
über die Zeit haben beide Seiten so
viele Fehler gemacht also sowohl die
arabischen Staaten weil die haben ja den
Krieg angefangen nicht die Palästinenser
und auch die israelische Politik unter
der die Palästinenser
Leiden das jetzt im Grunde genommen für
mich auch um sozusagen wie so eine
Ursünde der
UN um auch wieder Reputation zu bekommen
in ihrer Handlungsfähigkeit ohnehin dass
da wirklich ganz ganz groß der Fokus
drauf gelegt werden muss um dort endlich
für die Menschen für alle eine ja
Wohltat zu sein als Vereinte Nationen
Frau grau ich verstehe Ihre Frage
richtig sie beziehen sich jetzt
tatsächlich auf den ursprünglichen Plan
von 1947 also sie sehen der Konflikt ist
schon sehr lang und die UN könnte
möglicherweise diesen jetzt umsetzen
Herr Bickel aber seitdem hat sich ja
auch einiges getan was meinen Sie in der
Tat hat sich einiges getan vielleicht
1947 zurückgenommen ein Teil der nie
umgesetzt wurde war Jerusalem zu einer
internationalen Stadt zu machen unter
unmandat und ich glaube wenn wir jetzt
wirklich nicht den ganzen Nahen Osten
ins Visier nehmen sondern den Gaza
Streifen dann braucht es eine Art
internationales Mandat Israel wird alles
tun um zu verhindern dass die Vereinten
Nationen dieses bekommen israel hat sehr
schlechte Erfahrung mit den Vereinten
Nationen auch im Libanon ist seit
1978 die Unifilm mission and trotz
dieser UNIFIL blau Helme 10000 Soldaten
sind es zurzeit kann die hisbolla im
Süden Libanons tun und walten wie sie
will insofern die Vereinten Nationen
werden wie 47 wahrscheinlich
wiederscheitern deshalb glaube ich dass
die neuen Verbündeten Israels Marokko
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate auch
Katar auch wenn es kein Verbündeter ist
eine wichtige Rolle spielen werden und
last but not least Saudi-Arabien m
danke und danke Frau Gronau für Ihre
Frage wir gehen weiter nach landzut zu
Janusch dutkowski guten Tag guten Tag
sie dürfen jetzt der Runde Ihre Frage
stellenitte hallo hallo alle
äh ich komme zurück auf die zwei
stattenlösung
äh weil
äh was mich stört bei der Geschichte ist
die unglaubliche Naivität denn
Palästinenser wollen
Hauptstadt also Jerusalem als eigene
Hauptstadt haben und dann bevor das
passiert stirbt er J der Israeli und äh
deswegen glaube ich auch dass die
Gedanken als zwei Staaten soll man
einfach verwerfen und auf die
Moslim
quasi also die musoslim auch an den
Tisch bitten also westliche Welt ist
nicht in der Lage dort zu helfen und
wenn die Saudis und anderen mitmachen
und sagen macht Wort dann wird das
gerettet auf jeden Fall
zweiattenlösung ist nicht möglich und
sie sie sie genau sie fragen ist das
eine unmögliche Idee vor allem weil es
das Problem mit Jerusalem als als
Hauptstadt gibt das ja auch damals 1947
explizit ausgeklammert wurde und diese
Frage nicht gelöst wurde Frau Sauerbrei
was antworten Sie Herr dutkowski also
natürlich kann man angesichts der ich
verstehe das sehr dass man angesichts
der Verhältnisse wie sie im Moment sind
und angesichts des Hasses der sich da
jeden Tag entlät das Gefühl hat dass
jeder Versuch ein diplomatischen Lösung
irgendwie naiv wirkt aber man kann ja
nur sozusagen verschiedene Modelle
nebeneinander legen und überlegen was
ist das was noch am realistischen wäre
umzusetzen und
bei der zweiaatenlösung wäre mein Gefühl
da gibt es eben schon
viele Vorarbeiten es gab schon einen
langen diplomatischen Prozess in dem
viele Fragen diskutiert worden sind
natürlich hat sich seitdem auch die
Realität am Boden vor allen Dingen
westgörderland auch sehr stark verändert
es sind Siedlungen hinzugekommen es ist
ein wahnsinnig hoher Anteil von
israelischer Bevölkerung dazu gekommen
für die man auch eine Lösung finden
müsste sie haben die Jerusalem Frage die
ungelöste angesprochen aber trotzdem
gibt es irgendwie Punkte an die man an
die man ansetzen könnte und es
sind immer noch diese Linien die sich
ganz grob mit vielen Inseln um die
Siedlungsgebiete auch drum herum Ranken
und andere Modelle einfach zu sagen ja
gut dann entvölkern wir den
gasaastreifen oder wir stellen es alles
dauerhaft unter israelische
Militärverwaltung oder wir machen einen
komplizierten föderativstaat aus beidem
da sehe ich noch weniger Zustimmung noch
weniger Möglichkeit von daher wäre
tatsächlich meine naive
mein mein mein naives me so Intuition
ähm zu sagen ja gut das ist das womit
man vielleicht jetzt als erstes mal
anfangen sollte drüber zu reden es geht
ja auch gar nicht so darum dass man
schon den den endplan da irgendwie Z auf
dem Tisch hat sondern dass man zumindest
mal so eine Vision und so ein Startpunkt
hat so läuft das ja immer und ich glaube
ganz wichtiger Schritt wä z.B von
israelischer Seite mal so ein Moratorium
gegen ähm so besetzt gegen so Besetzung
hausabrisse und sowas seit das was ja in
Ostjerusalem vor allen Dingen passiert
ist dass da ganz oft so über Nacht
plötzlich dann
Häuser besetzt werden von von Siedl oder
auch in Hebron ist das ein ganz großes
ganz großes Problem und da mal
Moratorium zu setzen und da mal auch
weil das liegt in der macht das kann man
auch durchsetzen ähm und solche
symbolischen Schritte glaube ich sind
für für vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen
braucht man immer um irgendwie sowas in
Gang zu bringen und da gibt's ganz
konkrete Sachen die man machen kann ohne
dass man jetzt sich vormacht innerhalb
von einem Jahr ein abschließendes
Friedensabkommen zu haben hm wir haben
mindestens noch eine Frage nämlich
Andreas Haus aus March im Breisgau hallo
einen schönen guten Tag Haus ja
es ist natürlich alles fürchterlich
kompliziert und äh was so immer
kompliziert ist heißt noch längst nicht
dass es nicht machbar ist äh itakraabin
und Arafat haben schon Vorarbeiten
geleistet nur sind beide tot trotzdem
die Vorarbeiten existieren es existiert
internationales Recht äh und dazu zählt
die UN-Resolution 242 die muss immer
noch umgesetzt werden und es existiert
ein Grundgesetz das uns als deutsche
verpflichtet sich nachhaltig und un äh
unwiderruflich sozusagen äh für äh die
für das Völkerrecht einzusetzen das
heißt Artikel 25 und 26 sagen äh unser
Völkerrechts geht's äh jedem Gesetz und
jeder äh komischen Einstellung von einem
Herrn Scholz und Co geht das vor und und
herus und ihre Frage bitte Ihre Frage
bitte ja äh die die äh Frage ist warum
stellen sie sich nicht auf die Position
des Rechts sondern sagen ich glaube
dieses ich glaube jenes Katar könnte
sich einmischen und Iran sei so wichtig
und dieses und jenes wir sind wichtig
die deutsche Haltung und das Recht die
deutsche Haltung und das Recht Herr
Bickel wir sind fast schon am Ende der
Sendung aber ich bin mir sicher dass sie
noch auf hern Haus antworten können die
deutsche Haltung und das Recht werden
den Nahostkonflikt allein nicht lösen
können es braucht die internationale
Gemeinschaft und ich glaube wenn sich
arabische Staaten aktiv beteiligen ist
es ein Schritt nach
vornut desland alleine kann es nicht
richten so lapidar an dieser Stelle die
Einschätzung zur Situation wir sind am
Ende dieses Presseclubs nachgefragt
angekommen ich bedanke mich bei meinen
Mitdiskutanten hier für die tolle und
interessante Runde und vor allem bei
Ihnen für Ihr Interesse einen schönen
Sonntag noch machen sie es gut
[Musik]
tschüss
gibt es eines der letzten Naturparadiese
unserer Erde hier